aquí tenemos una representación de un
derivado de ácido carboxílico donde está
este sustituyente y enlazado al
carbonilo sabemos que los carbonilos son
reactivos porque este
oxígeno está quitando algo de densidad
electrónica de nuestro carbono
carbonílico haciéndolo parcialmente
positivo y para los derivados de nuestro
ácido carboxílico nuestro sustituyente
es un átomo electronegativo también por
lo que este quitará incluso más densidad
electrónica de nuestro carbono
carbonílico Así que continuemos
escribiendo el primer efecto el efecto
inductivo la inducción es un efecto de
retiro de electrones estamos quitando
densidad electrónica de nuestro carbono
carbonílico Y eso hace a nuestro carbono
carbonílico más parcialmente positivo
por lo que es más electrofílico y más
capaz de reaccionar con un nucleófilo Y
entonces la inducción aumenta la
reactividad de un derivado del ácido
carboxílico este efecto incrementa la
reactividad tenemos efectos de inducción
con resonancia compitiendo pensemos
ahora en la re so
nancia nuestro sustituyente y con un par
libre de electrones puede donar algo de
densidad electrónica a nuestro carbono
carbonílico Y si dibujamos nuestra
estructura
resonante podemos ver que que nuestro
oxígeno de aquí arriba tendrá una carga
formal de
men1 y tendremos un enlace un enlace pi
entre nuestro carbono y nuestro
sustituyente
y dándole a nuestra y una carga formal
de +
1 nuevamente este concepto de
incrementar la densidad electrónica
desde este par de electrones a nuestro
carbono
carbonílico eso incrementa la densidad
electrónica es un efecto de donación de
electrones y si estás donando densidad
electrónica estás disminuyendo la carga
parcial positiva haciéndola menos
electrofílica y Por ende haciéndola
menos reactiva con el nucleófilo la
resonancia va a disminuir la re AC
idad de un derivado del ácido
carboxílico Y entonces tenemos estos dos
efectos compitiendo entre la inducción y
la resonancia y cualquiera de los dos
que gane podemos pensar en este balance
para ayudarnos a determinar la
reactividad de nuestros derivados de
ácido
carboxílico empezamos con un cloruro de
asilo o ácido
con nuevamente el efecto inductivo el
oxígeno quitará algo de densidad
electrónica de nuestro carbono
carbonílico y lo mismo hace nuestro
cloro Por lo que tenemos un fuerte
efecto inductivo si piensas en la
posibilidad de resonancia movería estos
electrones a acá y empujaría esos
electrones al
oxígeno déjame dibujar la posible
estructura
resonante nuevamente una carga formal de
-1 en el
oxígeno y una carga formal de + un en el
cloro el cual tiene Solo dos parel
libres de electrones alrededor ahora si
pensamos en esta estructura resonante
tenemos un enlace pi entre el carbono y
el cloro Y si dibujamos el orbital
p el carbono está en el segundo periodo
dibujamos un orbital p para el segundo
periodo y si pensamos en el cloro el
cloro está en el tercer periodo por lo
que tiene un orbital p mayor y resulta
que cuando no empatan los tamaños no
pueden traslaparse también por lo que un
traslape de orbitales pobre significa
que el cl no está donando mucha densidad
electrónica a nuestro carbono
carbonílico aquí por lo que este no es
un gran contribuyente en el híbrido de
resonancia global y entonces la
inducción dominará déjame continuar
escribiendo eso aquí usaré este color
doina la
in
c y si la inducción domina entonces
esperaríamos que los cloruros de asilo o
ácido fueran extremadamente reactivos y
de hecho lo son reaccionarán con
agua algunas veces violentamente a
temperatura ambiente veamos nuestro
siguiente derivado del ácido carboxílico
que es un anhídrido de ácido nuevamente
pensamos en inducción primero por lo que
este oxígeno está quitando algo de
densidad electrónica de este carbono lo
mismo hace este oxígeno y si piensas que
este es tu sustituyente
y tienes este otro oxígeno aquí que
puede
contribuir nuevamente tenemos un efecto
inductivo fuerte y cuando pensamos en
resonancia podría mover este par libre
de electrones del oxígeno a acá y
empujar estos electrones a acá y
entonces estamos pensando en traslapar
nuestros orbitales del oxígeno y el
carbono Esta es una mejor situación que
antes porque el carbono y el oxígeno
están en el mismo periodo de la tabla
periódica por aquí tenemos carbono y
oxígeno mismo periodo por lo que tienen
orbitales p de tamaños similares lo que
significa un mejor traslape por lo tanto
hay más contribución hay más efecto de
donación de electrones que en nuestro
ejemplo
anterior si piensas en un par libre de
electrones de nuestro oxígeno
incrementando la densidad electrónica
alrededor de este carbono carbonílico
aquí y por lo tanto disminuyendo la
reactividad sin embargo el efecto
inductivo aún domina al efecto resonante
y una manera de pensar en eso es que
aquí tenemos una estructura resonante en
Competencia por lo que este par libre de
electrones puede moverse acá y esos
electrones se van al
oxígeno Parece que la densidad
electrónica no toda se dona al carbono
carbonílico en la izquierda algo de la
densidad electrónica está yendo a al
carbono carbonílico aquí en la derecha
la resonancia no es un efecto tan grande
como la inducción la inducción aún
domina aquí es más fuerte continuemos
escribiendo eso la
inducción es mucho más fuerte que la
resonancia la
inducción
es
mucho más
fuerte que la
resonancia esperaríamos que un anhídrido
de ácido fuera muy reactivo porque la
inducción incrementa la reactividad Y
eso es lo que observamos en general los
anhídridos de ácido son reactivos
reaccionarán con agua algo como
anhídrido acético reaccionará con agua a
temperatura ambiente por lo que la
inducción nuevamente es el efecto más
fuerte continuemos con el siguiente
derivado del ácido carboxílico el cual
es un Ester nuevamente pensamos en
inducción por lo que este oxígeno quita
algo de densidad Electrónica lo mismo
hace este cuando pensamos en resonancia
movemos a este par libre a acá y movemos
esos electrones a este
oxígeno no tenemos una estructura en
competencia esta vez por lo que el
efecto resonante es un poco más
importante que antes y entonces hay un
equilibrio más cercano entre la
inducción y la resonancia sin embargo la
inducción gana aún por lo que la
inducción es más fuerte pero está más
cerca que el ejemplo anterior entonces
la
in
ducción la inducción es
más
fuerte bien movámonos ahora al último
derivado del ácido carboxílico que es la
amida nuevamente este oxígeno quita algo
de densidad electrónica de este carbono
el nitrógeno es un poco más
electronegativo que el carbono por lo
que podemos pensar en esa posibilidad
cuando consideramos que el efecto
resonante mueve este par libre de
electrones a acá empujando a esos
electrones a tu oxígeno y dibujamos
nuestra estructura resonante para la
amida nuestro oxígeno arriba obtiene una
carga formal de -1 y tendríamos ahora
nuestro nitrógeno doblemente enlazado a
este carbono pondré estos
hidrógenos aquí y hay una carga formal
de + un en el
nitrógeno Y entonces en este
caso Este es un contribuyente principal
al híbrido global cierto esta estructura
resonante aquí déjame continuar e
identificarlo Este es el
contribuyente
prin
cal al híbrido global y sabemos esto
porque el enlace carbono nitrógeno tiene
un carácter de doble enlace
significativo debido a esta estructura
resonante y Esta es una estructura mucho
más importante que la que no dibujé pero
en la que podríamos pensar aquí para el
Ester y la razón es porque el nitrógeno
no es tan electronegativo como el
oxígeno es más probable que el nitrógeno
Don su par libre de electrones que este
oxígeno y Por ende esta estructura
resonante es más
contribuyente otra manera de decir eso
es que el elemento menos electronegativo
es el que tiene mayor probabilidad de
formar una carga de +1 Entonces estamos
donando mucha densidad electrónica a
nuestro carbono
carbonílico Por ende estamos
disminuyendo la reactividad y ya que
tenemos un contribuyente principal al
híbrido global aquí resulta Resulta ser
que el efecto resonante es más
importante que el efecto inductivo
escribiré aquí que esta vez la
resonancia gana la
resonancia
domina a la inducción
Y si la resonancia domina a la inducción
entonces esperaríamos que la amida fuera
relativamente no reactiva Y eso es por
supuesto lo que observamos hablamos de
la inducción y la resonancia para estos
cuatro derivados de ácidos carboxílicos
y podemos ver ahora una Clara tendencia
en términos de reactividad mientras te
mueves hacia arriba En esta dirección te
volverás más reactivo los cloruros de
asilo o ácido son los más reactivos
porque la inducción domina y las amidas
son las menos
reactivas porque la resonancia domina y
es importante entender esta tendencia
para la reactividad y especialmente
podemos pensar en biología porque por
ejemplo en el cuerpo humano hay muchos
ésteres y hay muchas amidas y son los
menos reactivos que mencionamos
no hay cloruros de asilo o anhídridos de
ácido serían demasiado reactivos para el
cuerpo humano y entonces esto nuevamente
tiene aplicaciones en la biología y en
la
medicina